you're joining us in a key area which is
just outside kiev it's very uh
logistically important because this is
one of the main routes
still open out of the capital with me as
the former president petro poroshenko
you've come here taken up arms yourself
oh good to meet you sir um thank you for
joining sky news live on the k burley
show tell us a little bit about first of
all why you're here we're not mentioning
the place because of security reasons
why is this place fundamental and what
do you think the west the international
community should be doing at this point
first of all i want to thank the sky
news for being here this is being deadly
dangerous because just this night we
have a 17 cruise missiles which hit
hitting also civilian object and kiev
but it is vitally important to protect
ukraine and uh having an opportunity
given to us by brave ukrainian soldiers
to stop putting troops in the 12th day
keeping russia outside of kiev
protecting here mean protecting ukraine
keep ukrainian sovereignty and
territorial integrity and with this
situation this is the key of oblast and
this is one of the main stronghold where
we create the battalion
one week ago and today you see that we
deliver here
all necessary things supply radio
station night version
the
machine gun the uniform uh
everything they need just to increase
their effectiveness ukrainian
if you close this route
the whole of capital is going to be in
circles we just we exactly we just do
our best on the different uh
location not allow them to go further
yesterday you know we save our lives
yesterday and day before yesterday we
save our lives two and a half thousand
people only our battalion helped to
evacuate providing the buses and
military protection and having uh
opportunity to see what's happening
after russia attack european where we
evacuate that was a
disastrous picture with the
dead civilians
in the
cathedral of orthodox cathedral in the
school and they are just lying on the uh
roads killing by russian uh criminals
i was in european yesterday how
confident are you about any humanitarian
corridor succeeding at the moment and
what do you have to say about is an
advancing force which is attacking
civilians this is my nice question and i
think that please don't trust putin
putin never keep their promises about
humanitarian corridor during the eight
years of war would you never keep
promises for the releasing the hostages
during eight years of war and i'm not
very much optimistic frankly speaking i
wish all the best i keep my fingers
crossed but i'm not very much optimistic
with the
negotiation group which now are on the
border below russia because
we
need to be united and this is not a war
against ukraine this is not a war
against ukrainian
this is the war against our values the
war against the whole west against us
against europe against the uk
and everybody should understand that
under negotiation we also should be
together
i really i'm admiring the leading uh
leadership which president biden
demonstrate
i really admiring which administration
congress demonstrate but we definitely
need we need a plane
military jet
and the poland are ready to give it to
us some european nation ready to give it
to us but they want to replace
old soviet uh military jet which they
given to ukraine by uh f-16 or
a10 or any other model of which
protecting their scale will that work
will that be enough i am absolutely
confident that there is we have no other
way out like to have the play now
because we need to protect our airspace
we don't need now the american pilot we
don't need now the american soldiers we
just give us the opportunity to protect
you
this is very simple and point number two
don't buy russian gas because
every single dollar you spend them this
is the dollar for the russian soldier
please
uh introduce the embargo of the russian
oil are you happy with what britain is
doing because we've got a lot of russian
money in britain
are they doing absolutely great and i
have a
very positive experience for
communication with the prime minister
boris johnson in his capacity as a
foreign secretary and is his capacity as
his prime minister and i think he was
one of the first he was also the leader
for introducing the sanction to arrest
the russian assets not only
the
assets in british bank or the
the great is it enough and is it going
to work this is not enough and my idea
is every single day why the putin
continued to kill ukrainian civilians
why the putin
stay not only an aggressor but he is a
military criminal for the crimes against
humanity we should introduce every
single day new sanctions we can frozen
into we can introduce the swift ban for
all the russian banks we can introduce
prohibition using credit card for all of
russian citizens because they
support putin they vote for this
criminal and they
approved the killing of ukrainian one
one more question
one more question i want to ask the
former president uh we saw civilians
killed and injured yesterday our own sky
news crew led by stuart ramsey been
attacked and escaped with their lives
the do you how much of a an
international war crime do you think
that is and what should be done about
that
i'm absolutely confident we are create a
special legal group who collect in all
the evidence and we will present it to
mass media to the world media and we
presented that to international criminal
court and with that situation definitely
putin and all his general and all his uh
uh
who is blessing this aggression should
have responsibility and you doing expect
extremely important role because you are
independent eyewitness who uh who's
seeing the dead ukrainian civilians who
see and how brave ukrainian soldiers
look these
guys don't have a weapons yet this is
the first weapon almost this is the
first weapon they deliver but they are
risky of hair of their lives for the 12
days
trotting trying to stop uh russian
soldiers just uh these uh just yesterday
the russian uh missile attack the oil
storage here and we finished the fire
just ten minutes before our arrival yeah
and this is just a demonstration we are
decisive we are ready to stop and
together we definitely win putin thank
you very much so you've given us a lot
of your time thank you very much thank
you we'll see you there thank you uh
thank you very much kay for for bearing
with us a very passionate man um he's
had a a little bit of an unhappy check
in history in ukraine but now he's
soaring high in the opinion polls
because he is with the current president
and really trying to rally the troops
and and get them including the
volunteers the many many thousands of
volunteers who are ready to fight to
defend their country and just before i
let you go um alex we have seen what
happened to one of our team on the
ground we've seen so many people that i
mean we've seen several hundred
civilians dead i'm sure that number will
increase significantly when the true uh
cost of this war this bloody war
comes to our attention but in the
meantime what is it like
on the ground now do you get the feeling
that these people are defiant are they
beaten are they determined to take on
putin tell me
i think if it was only based on defiance
and determination and courage there
wouldn't be any contest ukraine would be
absolutely ahead of head of everything
and would would defeat the much bigger
superior stronger
military that russia has but that's not
enough to to do it and unfortunately
what we've seen just in the few days
that we've been in the capital is that
the capital is really digging in and
hunkering the whole of the the center of
the capital has changed with massive um
concrete blocks trenches um to try and
hunker down but the russian troops are
definitely making ground unfortunately
they are definitely making ground
yesterday and the day before we were
able to go quite far down the road into
into urban
yesterday was even less
uh now they're trying to create some
sort of corridor but we know from the
civilians that they have made quite a
lot of headway into urban it hasn't
fallen yet but that is on the outskirts
of kiev it they really are just a hop
skip and a jump away from the capital
there now this where i am now is the
only route out if they if because they
can't civilians can't get out through
urban anymore that the the capital is
virtually
encircled there's no there's no safe
route out apart from
where the south the southern route down
to odessa and you'd have to skip a
desert because that's also being
attacked and and try and get out that
way so unfortunately the russians are
the russian military is moving closer
and is making headway it's been slow but
it is making headway so
there's a real heightened sense of of um
we've got to hunker down in kiev and
we've got to build up defenses and
that's exactly what they've spent the
last 24 48 hours every time you go
outside there's new defenses built
there's new trenches there's new blocks
roadblocks so
um things are not necessarily moving in
the right direction for ukraine and and
certainly there's a i think amongst the
civilians and the population there's a
feeling that they're fighting they're
definitely not ready to give up
but
it's difficult to know which way it's
going to go right now